hey cinephiles here's our list of the
top 5 most anticipated movies at the
2014 tribeca film festival number 5
beyond the break the lego brick you
memory written and directed by Keith
Davidson and Daniel Jun's the lego movie
took the world by storm earlier this
year paving the perfect lead-up to a
documentary about the plastic bricks
that have infused generations of
children and grown-ups alike with the
task of creative construction beyond the
brick provides a look at the global
culture and appeal of the lego building
block toys number four third person
written and directed by paul haggis
despite what you might think of haggis
directorial work he has enough solid
writing credits in his portfolio to
prove he can tackle big stories in
intimate ways this time around he's
dealing with three interlocking love
stories involving three couples in three
cities Rome Paris and New York cast
includes Mila Kunis James Franco Olivia
Wilde
Liam Neeson Adrien Brody Kim Basinger
and Maria Bello number three begin again
written and directed by John Carney
previously known as can a song save your
life this is the story about a dejected
music business executive who forms a
bond with a young singer-songwriter new
to Manhattan Carney previously stole our
hearts and ears with once and were
hoping he can do it again
a star-studded cast replete with a-list
actors and big-name singers adds to the
allure number two black coal they nice
written and directed by D ow anam after
winning the Golden Bear at the Berlin
International Film Festival Yao's latest
films skyrocketed on our radar with a
plot synopsis that sounds a lot like
true detective and the incredible wave
of contemporary crime films coming out
of China black hole thin ice is a
must-see number 1 Night Moves written
and directed by Kelly Rijkaard a drama
centered on three environmentalist who
plot to blow up a dam Rijkaard has
established herself has an icon among
female filmmakers and the neo
neo-realist movement this is her
follow-up to the revisionist Western
Meeks cut off and similarly includes a
more well-known and exciting cast to
Kota Fanning Jesse Eisenberg and Peter
Sarsgaard that's our list of the top 5
most anticipated films of the 2014
tribeca film festival what films are you
looking forward to let us know in the
comments below and thanks for watching